foreign
I like TV on at night do you guys like
TV on at night no no
oh this is gonna be a long time can I
ask you a question yeah please you know
before I go to bed I masturbate yeah
there's a rule we didn't talk about yeah
before I go to bed every night I'll be
sleeping on the bus right we are so what
does one do
you have to go outside you have to go
outside in the woods yeah well it
doesn't have to be the woods it can be
the fields but you have to jerk off the
Bad friends theater tour has officially
been underway for a few weeks now with
Bobby Lee Andrew Santino and the rest of
the crew hitting the road together for
the first time ever with just 25 stops
remaining it's time for all of us to
take a deeper look at what attending a
bad friend's live show is really like is
it a podcast is it stand up does Bobby
Lee keep his clothes on all that more is
coming up next in episode 49 of the joke
World comedy news update starting off
with the set design each show has taken
place in a theater style venue with a
recreation of the bad Friends Podcast
Studio on stage behind them which looks
dope the night starts off with 25
minutes of stand up from juicy jet ski
Johnson Bobby Lee and Andrew Santino
with the occasional appearances from
other members of the bad friends
Universe like Carlos and fancy B from
there bull fatitos sit down for about an
hour of live podcasting full of fan
interaction questions and plenty of
callbacks to Classic bad friends moments
and songs like Daddy while you die to
close out the show we gotta go to La and
they're awesome man I wish we could have
went to their live show they're touring
around doing their podcast live show
Santino that's funny oh you went they
did about an hour of stand up between
three of them and then they did one hour
of the full live show and man they are
dialed in they did a really good job of
just segments and always like never
leaving Dead Space hats off to them and
like the whole production team and they
were super nice to us they had us back
after the show we were hanging with them
uh all around 4.5 on the show oh nice
you have any uh how was how did their
live show compare to our live show
you know oh that's all I need to hear
one of the darker things that's been on
every comedy Fan's mind in regards to
this tour is how Bobby's been handling
being on the road while simultaneously
dealing with the trolls on Tick Tock who
have been trying to cancel him although
the criticism has been slowly dying off
as of late it still sucks that Bobby has
to handle this during what should just
be a really fun tour unless this is the
perfect distraction we had a really nice
moment Bobby and I yeah really nice
because you know I mean I've had a
really bad couple weeks and like you
know that that show happened at the
right time it was awesome it was awesome
that's what Andrew's been saying I knew
I said it I said this is exactly what we
need to start the tour in Vancouver with
a big huge audience of people in Canada
that were like so excited to come out it
was so we were leaving I go let's go we
got the cars here or whatever and she
goes um no I want to go back on the
stage again so I went with her I made
him come with me oh and she goes look
and you know this beautiful theater such
a pretty theme box on the ceiling I
could see her cheer up right and I went
you know what you just taught me a
lesson this is it this is it this is it
there's nothing else living it right now
right now you really taught me Alaska I
was so glad because I didn't tell you at
the time but I think it was because I
was pretty drunk
so it wasn't a real emotion no it's
surreal but it was fueled but you but
you were like are you getting emotional
and then I was like yeah and then you
started
you weren't emotional then you were
Faking It Well I didn't want to tell you
I think a lot of it was because of the
alcohol yeah
I had a spiritual profound moment you
were [__] drunk now whenever a
podcast announces a big tour like this I
feel like it's always a little bit
unclear to the fans exactly what's gonna
happen on stage most of the time live
podcasts in front of an audience in a
theater are cool to witness but rarely
turn out to be funnier than the normal
studio recorded episodes this bad
Friends tour seems to have the perfect
mix of stand-up comedy and podcast
comedy to give fans The Ultimate Live
experience Susanna now look now we're on
a tour where we're doing 33 cities we do
we both do stand-ups so you get both of
us doing 25 30 minutes to stand up then
we do another hour and a half if not
more of bits from the podcast that we've
done over the years we interact with
fans we have so it's like we grew this
new audience we already had stand-up
audiences yeah but we grew like another
chunk so it was it's changed our lives
in a way that was so happy about man
yeah go ahead but friends has not
uploaded any official long-form footage
from any of these shows yet but if you
want to check it out for yourself
tickets are still on sale right now at
badfriendspod.com there's still a little
less than two months left on this tour
I'm gonna go to the show and St Pete let
me know if you're going to be there as
well some more podcasting history for
you this week the first ever taste buds
live streaming event is set to take
place Wednesday May 10th at 9pm Eastern
Joe DeRosa and South volcano have both
really been hyping this event up and it
seems like it's going to be a big hit
they've promised plenty of special
guests big surprises and a taste buds
first live voting so you can weigh in
during the battle which when it comes to
the live podcasting thing I think in
studio is definitely the way to go this
is a one-time event not a whole tour
like bad friends so the majority of
viewers are going to be watching online
and filming in studio helps the content
translate a lot better to the internet
taste buds live is only 10 bucks if you
buy tickets ahead of time on moment.com
and get you access to the stream for a
full week let me know in this video's
comments if you plan on checking this
thing out and if you are I'll see you in
the live chat on May 10th guest spots
from last week your mom's house did not
have a guest two bears one cave was Tom
and Janus Papas kiltoni this week was
with Sam Talent whiskey Ginger had on
Sami Zayn we might be drunk head on
nemish Patel Casey neistat was on
flagrant Ryan sickler was a guest on the
honest Papa sour and Andrew Schultz was
a guest on the boys cast I don't think I
honestly think they're having like a bit
of an identity crisis they really don't
know like what they are because there's
all these like even hard more hardcore
racist groups you know I feel like that
look down on the cake kind I think
they're kind of these guys are soft yeah
they're just like you guys are like the
old hats take off the hoods you [__]
yeah exactly show your face hide in your
identity this guy's like yeah but I work
at Whataburger right I'm a police
officer I can't dude yeah it just feels
like so embarrassing outside of it being
racist like even amongst racists it
feels embarrassing that's what I mean if
you were like thinking of you know
getting into that game I think that
watching them get clowned on makes it
less appealing than people calling it so
what if you were racist and you just you
couldn't make the cut like was it more
invented you in the not enough they're
like no trust me I [__] hate them
dude they're destroying the
neighborhoods you do not want to see me
when an Asian Cuts me off
you do not how do you prove it if there
was a GoPro in my car I swear to God
this past weekend with the Yvonne talked
with Glennie balls Jim Norton was on
chaos The Joe Rogan Experience had on
Miss Pat gelling Summers was on
tigerbelly Josh Blue was on the Honeydew
Keenan Thompson was on the blocks
podcast take your shoes off talk with
Lauren Ash and Tim Dillon was a guest on
you know what dude
thinks I should move to LA you go up Joe
Rogan told me to move to L.A I would
leave my wife and my kid now
if you told me to move to L.A now not
even Austin yeah I want you to go to L.A
you go if Joe Rogan told me to move he
goes I would kiss Dawn goodbye and I
said I love you Max I'll see you next
month yeah see you later see you later
with a big fat paycheck here's the deal
because we've been talking you went to
LA because of Rogan oh yeah well because
like the scene was there and Rogan said
to me he's like you would do well here
sometimes you just need somebody to go
you would do well here because I didn't
know if I would or not I I it's weird
it's different place and I tried it out
and it was good and um you know it he
was like he helped out a lot but I
helped him more than he helped me
probably 100 can I give you advice I
don't know I get jokes anymore I have no
idea as far as brand new stand-up
specials go that are either coming out
soon or out right now nemesh Patel lucky
Lefty came out on YouTube yesterday
that's a brand new 40 minutes of stand
up from one of the best comedians
working today that you can watch for
free right after this video other
specials out right now Jay Larson sounds
like Bruce is up on YouTube as well as
Ashley Gavin live in Chicago and Luke
cagel cheers to that and for those of
you who recently checked out John
mulaney's new special Baby J on Netflix
feel free to join the joke World Discord
server and let me know your thoughts on
the new special make sure to keep an eye
out for the best of April compilation
coming out on this channel very soon
last month featured some of the funniest
podcast moments in a while so you're
definitely not going to want to miss it
in fact you might as well just subscribe
and turn on the post notifications just
to be safe thanks for watching
foreign
[Music]